all right so i was reading the uh the
production notes for the movie and
there's a quote from you saying that
ramsay evolved from your very first
conversation about the character to what
we see in the finished film so what
would you say is the biggest difference
between ramsay day one and what we see
in what's on the big screen now uh
ramsey has written in the initial script
was uh was um a lot
less
sure of himself a lot less confident a
little um
uh i i wonder if colin would take
umbrage with the word i'm about to use
but um a little silly
um
you know he had like some kind of uh
well not maybe not silly but he was
certainly um
he was just certainly less sure of
himself in a way that i was like oh i
think he needs
to have a kind of steel about him in
making these choices rather than
being put upon and just like having the
wind blow him in which every which way i
i thought he needed to make choices that
were uh action-oriented and colin agreed
and we just went from there and you know
created a kind of a brand new character
which i thought was really cool and a
very very unique situation for a
director in production to be willing and
open and
also come in with ideas on top of that
that made it the guy who he is so a
brand new character but someone who
technically in the film franchise world
lived through or at least from afar saw
the events unfold at jurassic park
jurassic world so did you put much
thought into how ramsay's opinion on
what unfolded at those parks influenced
who he became and what position he's in
now absolutely absolutely and i think
you know i i i but i also think there's
a lot of things that uh he didn't he
wasn't privy to i don't think he was
privy to who louis dodgson actually is
you know and then he finds out
and you know as
as i'm sure everyone's experienced you
it's disappointing when you find out
somebody who you'd consider maybe a hero
is uh not who you thought they were
um so but the thing that i love about
him is that he takes steps to change he
makes change happen from within and and
uh
you know it's a great consequence in the
movie so an important character to have
added to a franchise on the corporate
side of things i like seeing those
characters there seems to be more and
more of them with every film and that's
why this one leaves me with some hope in
the end yeah cool i'm glad to hear it so
there's disappointment obviously when he
finds out who dodgson is in the end but
what about when they first meet though
like what what is it about louis dodgson
that makes ramsay think like this is a
guy that i'm willing to let take me
under his wing and you know help me rise
in the ranks at bios and well i mean
like it's the bison the biosin is uh it
potentially
um uh incredibly exciting new
uh vista for like humanity it's
the potential is limitless
and so it's like all right i have this
opportunity and this guy yeah he's a
little weird but he has like ideas and
you know he has a he wants to involve
you know young people and like this
entire think tank of of just like bright
young minds and
and then he finds out oh this is this
dude wants to make money
this dude just wants to make money it's
incredibly disappointing it's kind of a
relatable thought process because it's
someone who's watched all these repeated
mistakes made throughout this franchise
if jurassic park or world opened up
tomorrow like
i'd go clearly i've learned nothing from
those movies but i would go
all right i gotta let you go clearly i
could talk about this franchise all day
long they're kicking me out though
congratulations enjoy the ride with this
one thank you
you